want to get back to uh one of the big
themes on Wall Street this weekend that
is crypto optimism over the odds for
future Bitcoin ETFs pushing that token
above $42,000 for the first time in a
year and a half now things have pulled
back just a little bit of smidge there $
41,9 right now um but we are still
looking at a roughly 20% gain that's
just in the last month alone crypto
investor Anthony Pomano is here is the
founder of poomp Investments and you are
now a New York resident again I am of
August so no I thought Miami was
supposed to be where it's at it it is
Griffin bunch of other people moving
Jeff Bezos uh I think that what you're
going to find is uh people want to live
both in a density of individuals like in
New York City and then people also want
to live uh where they think capital is
going to move and so that's a place like
Miami well maybe we'll get back to that
but let's let's talk crypto right now
and let's talk Bitcoin specifically
$442,000 what do you ascribe the move to
yeah uh Bitcoin is a free market asset
and I think one of the things people
forget in finance is that markets are
forward-looking and so what we're seeing
here is people are allocating to an
asset that they believe is going to go
up in the future obviously uh things
that will drive that are the Bitcoin ETF
but as people are allocating to this 70%
of the circulating supply of Bitcoin has
not moved in a year the reason why
that's important is this is an $800
billion asset that has gone up 150% over
the last 12 months so when an asset goes
up 150% you would expect people to sell
into the strength kind of take profits
that's not happening and so bitcoiners
are not selling that Bitcoin they're not
going to sell it to Wall Street and so
wall Street's going to have to continue
to bid up the price in order that share
issue so the 70% that has changed not
just this past year but by the way that
has not changed I don't think for many
many years it's always been very high
70% is the all-time high so it's been
creeping up which has this reflexive
kind of feedback loop right so if more
people won't sell and price goes up then
price continues to go up even more
rapidly okay the other 30% that is
moving yes do you think that that I mean
I don't know if you can look through
some of the numbers is that are those
new buyers are those the old buyers who
owned the original 70% saying I want
more more what is that so it's
interesting when you look at the data
it's a little bit of everything right
there's definitely more accumulation
happening so people who already had
Bitcoin are continue to buy more Bitcoin
uh an interesting statistic is if you
dollar cost average every single day
with $10 from January 1st until now
you're up 100% so with all the Boom the
bust everything in between uh a Bitcoin
analyst Dylan lir pointed out you're up
100% so just dollar cost averaging alone
give you a great return now there's also
this net new wave of capital coming in
so you have the institutions but also
you have a bunch of people sting on the
sidelines saying well if Black Rock
wants Bitcoin maybe I should buy some as
well and so that net new capital is
definitely starting to come in but I
don't think we're actually going to see
it until the gun goes but the real move
I think seemed to happen as a function
of this idea that the Federal Reserve
the new wisdom whether it's conventional
or otherwise uh or right even is that
they're going to ultimately have to turn
things around and lower interest rates
sometime in 2024 is that what you I mean
there was the ETF piece and everyone
said oh over here it's the ETF
oh no it's actually this markets are
forward looking and if you go back to
2021 Bitcoin started to fall as soon as
the FED started talking about we are
going to cut rates and so people were
like oh wait a second inflation is high
in the summer of 2022 why is Bitcoin
falling it's supposed to be this
inflation hedge asset but it was because
Bitcoin and the holders saw what was
going to happen same thing's happening
right now Bill amman's betting that
interest rates are going to get cut in
q1 the Market's pricing in 100% uh you
know likelihood of an interest rate cut
in Q2 Bitcoin right now and people who
want Bitcoin say it's going to happen
even earlier what is the share right now
um internationally of ownership of
Bitcoin meaning is it predominantly in
the United States is it predominantly in
China how if you were to make a pie
chart of the ownership on a like a a
globe what would that look like so uh
let's separate Bitcoin and hash rate
hash rate about 35% or so is in the
United States uh when China banned
mining the United States was the big
winner there uh ownership's a little bit
harder because there's so many wallets
of we don't know exactly geographically
where they are uh but you can see
Capital flows the United States uh and
Asia seem to really be driving a lot of
the capital flows right now uh the
European region is actually a little bit
behind and not allocating nearly as much
and so I think that America is going to
be a big winner in Bitcoin and
cryptocurrency race uh we see companies
being built here coinbase being a
fantastic example of 330% over the last
uh or year to date what we've watched is
Regulators have stepped in and they
basically are slapping the of anyone who
is not operating within the American
Financial system Michael sailor you know
has had uh I guess down at 177,000 there
were people that thought that he was
going to get like a margin call or
something he's back now I don't know how
much he bought something like how much
he's got 174,000 Bitcoin he's up2
billion on it he made some weird comment
the other day and that was about what
percentage of Global Financial system in
his view Bitcoin will represent at some
point and then he did some simple math
and came out with some crazy number what
what was it I saw there's all kinds of
numbers that fly it was like 5 to 10
million per coin or something was was
what he came up with if Bitcoin just
simply matches gold to be $500,000 if
it's 500,000 if it match just matches
gold at uh 20 um or I'm sorry $10
trillion now if you continue to look at
uh you know other assets it could eat
into if you have a dollar today and you
want to store wealth you historically
could have bought gold you could have
bought uh you know Fine Art you could
have bought all kind real estate
whatever hard hard young people are
saying to I want to buy the hardest
asset I can find which tends to be
Bitcoin and it's liquid and it is the
best performing asset over the last 10
years it's not a but the the Sailor
question is how much of it becomes part
of the quotequote financial system and
does it is he suggesting that there has
to be a payments element or an actual
transaction but he was saying gold you
weren't saying a payment if it became
part of the payment system it could be
much bigger well but it also if it
became part of and this goes back to can
it really part of the payment system and
have actual and continue to increase
because as we we've discussed a million
times if it keeps inreasing nobody's
ever going to use it to buy except there
there's that company we had on that uses
just little tiny little
pieces it doesn't matter the little
minuscule variations on a daily basis
whenever I talk to someone in private
and they ask me about Bitcoin I tell
them it's very simple if you think that
the Federal Reserve and other central
banks are going to have to print Capital
uh or print money in order to finance
all of this debt then you're going to
want to be in something other than
dollar and got get you're still not on
board been curious are you moreal but at
25,000 you were I was probably early on
my was number there was a number you
once said that if it hit that you would
think about buying a for kids 5000 bucks
5,000 right but at 25 you were really
saying this is way too now it's 42 you
got to eventually throw in the chat what
number where you'll say I'm I believe in
it 100 well I just think it's a very
because it's such a abstract concept
that it's like non-existent thing even
though I know it's a thing for some
people it I
think maybe I know it's a very
philosophical aren't there like s you
you can describe why gold is worse I
mean it's not because it's pretty and
it's not because it's used in jewelry
it's because it's immutable it's
crosscultural there's only so much
around and and there these are the
characteristics of money since the
beginning of time everybody has gold
corre value it's if you understand the
distributed Ledger nature of Bitcoin you
can see that it it can represent barter
for something here here's one of the
here's one of the crazy Parts about this
is a lot of people who question
bitcoin's uh efficacy or or legitimacy
they're using uh a worldview that is
dominate in traditional finance things
like intrinsic value things like
efficient market hypothesis Etc very
what we're watching though bless him
Charlie Monger view of the world
absolutely yeah and and by the way
you've been right for 50 years having
that world view I think that bitcoiners
are coming into the market and they're
saying wait a second there's a different
view of the world something like
intrinsic value if you and I both look
at an asset and I tell you the intrinsic
value is X you say it's y obviously
there's no intrinsic value it's just
what our opinion is Right safety with
efficient market hypothesis I think what
Bitcoin is really doing is it's showing
there's this new view of the world so
far it's been right and if it continues
to be right there will be trillions of
dollars that flow into the asset Anthony
papano a true New Yorker a true new
thank you guys thank you